[Music]
this is my perfect lasagna start by
finely chopping onion carrots and celery
add the your POA to a large pot with
butter and oil and sauté add in the
seasonings and follow with tomato paste
stirring constantly until you see it
darken in color the sugars will
caramelize adding richness and reducing
acidity next add ground beef ground pork
and Panetta and allow the heat to reduce
the sugars and proteins Browning our
meat this is known as the myard reaction
add milk wine and bring to a simmer and
add some oregano now for the ricotta
bashel start with butter in a pan over
medium low heat stir in the flour and
whisk constantly for 1 minute the
process of combining fat and flour
creates a thickening agent for our
sauce now add the milk and bring to a
simmer stir in the salt and Nutmeg and
let cool before folding in the ricotta
cheese slice three out Dente noodles
lengthwise to help fit the pan and let's
assemble start with the bamel then
noodles add another layer of ricotta
bashal then the bolog add some Parmesan
cheese and top with one more layer of
noodles and
repeat top with a final layer of bamel
Parmesan and mozzarella bake this
uncovered for 40 minutes and wow look at
that almost
perfect so what makes it perfect well
the best thing about lasagna is that it
can be built however you want perfect is
in the eye of the
beholder